welcome to drew's news summertime
edition
your trip to the lush news garden and
with me at the desk
he's got a mean news green thumb it's
rossi ross matthew hi everybody
hi hi and in honor of green we're going
green on this special summertime edition
of green news
first up we're talking about our carbon
footprint
that's the amount of greenhouse gases
that are created by our actions and
greenhouse gases are what's heating up
the planet
huff post reports that even small
changes in what we eat
can reduce our footprint experts say
that doing two simple things reducing
red meat and cutting back on dairy can
have a huge impact
you don't have to totally eliminate them
just reduce
and you'll be eating like a climatarian
are you making that word up climatarian
it's a monitor
but acclimatarian is actually a really
amazing thing because my daughter
olive she came in the other day and
she's like i'm a vegetarian now and i
was like
great but then that didn't last
and then i was like maybe we could be
pescetarians and she didn't know what
that meant so then
i taught her that so now i feel like i
want to go home and teach her about
climatarian
i think it's great because it's about
just everything in moderation which at
the end of the day you know you've heard
that and it's like i
roll when people say it but it's really
truly the best thing for you and it
turns out the best thing
for the planet as well i completely
agree rossi it's very well said
well thanks drew and you know there's
another way to cut back on meat
it's tricking your mouth with the fake
stuff of course we've seen
plant-based fake meat like beyond me and
impossible burgers well now town and
country reports that the latest
fake meat is actually real meat
but it's grown in a lab which grosses me
out in a weird way
it's not out quite yet but dozens of
companies are working on it
pork duck hamburgers ribeyes you name it
they say
they can grow it the science is okay i'm
not a scientist
it's a doozy but basically what they do
is they take a small cell sample from
like
a live cow and then they put it in
something and
they grow i don't know what but they
grow
thousands of pounds of meat from that
sample
but it's like not real except it is
critics hold on
are you are you as kind of blown away by
this as i am
i've actually studied this quite a bit
you have because this is
literally the first time i'm hearing
about it i have and uh for reid zakaria
on um his show gps yeah a phenomenal
piece on it i
highly recommend googling it and
watching it on youtube because
it really showed you the step by step of
what they're doing and when you see the
marbleization
when you see the synthetic nature it
doesn't look
it even makes impossible and beyond look
really fake i mean it is real meat
there's nothing different about it
it's just created in a different way i
don't know i
i hate to say it but i think i have a
real beef with
this idea anyway finally
and some other green news the disney
parks blog announced that there are
classic disney dolls we're talking belle
ariel anna and elsa and more will now
come
in plastic free packaging yes
thank you as a parent thank you so much
and instead they're going to come in
recyclable boxes
made of sustainably sourced paper and
look how cute
they're doing it rossi look at this it's
said to look
cute it's cute listen at the end of the
day we're not buying this because we
want the plastic
you you right you just want to get
through the plastic get to the toy
these companies are finally paying
attention to how important this is drew
i feel like they watch this show and
they hear what you're saying
right i i mean i would just be so i
think it's
the way of the world i think this is
how we proceed forward we here on this
show
will always celebrate every single
company
that decides to make this kind of a
change we will highlight you we will
complement you
and we will talk about the fact that you
are setting the benchmark for the future
so thank you disney thank you so much
for making the world a better place
and showing our children what is
important and i thank you so much i'm so
grateful
we can't do it without you thanks disney
thank you the happiest place on earth
just made earth a little happier
that's exactly right rossi see perfect
dovetail
well i love newsing with you and i thank
you so much for joining us
in the summertime on drew's news we hope
that you have a safe and fantastic
summer and we can't wait to see you
again very soon
[Music]
you